اضرابات ترتاح سجون ايران على خلفيه تصاعد
عمليات الاعدام حيث تواصلوا خمسه عشره
سجينا سياسيه ايرانيه في الاضراب عن
الطعام لليوم الثالث على التوالي فيما
اعلن محمد مهدي كرمي المتظاهر الايراني
المحكوم عليه بالاعدام عن دخوله في اضراب
عن الطعام احتجاجا على تاييد حكم اعدامه
ومع زياده الدخول الضغوط على المحتاجين
السجناء في ايران بدات موجته اضرابات عن
الطعام واسعه في السجون وورد التقرير تفيد
بتعرض صحه السجناء للخطر وفق ما افادت
ايران انترناشونال يجري ذلك فيما تتحدث
وانبا غير مؤكده عن اقاله قائد الشرطه
الايرانيه العميد حسن حسين اشتري بامر من
المرشد الاعلى الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
ولا حاجه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وتحت عنوان طلاب ايران يخاطرون بكل شيء
الا الانتفاضه ضد النظام من اجل الحريه
والتغيير كتبت صحيفه واشنطن بوسه
الامريكيه نقلا عنه شطاء ايرانينا قولهم
ان الثمن الذي يدفعه هذا الجيل من الطلبه
للمطالبه بحقوقهم اخذ في الارتفاع يوما
بعد يوم واصطى شهادات الايرانيين قابلتهم
الصحيفه متابع ما قلناه عن اقوال بعض
الطلاب والنشاطات
يتعرض الطلاب للقتل والاعتقال والمنع من
الحرم الجامعي ولهم احكام طويله بالسجن
[موسيقى]
النظام يزيد الضغط على الطلاب للحد الاقصى
بحيث ولا يمكنك المشي او ارتداء الملابس
او التحدث هو حتى الضحك بطريقه لا تتناسب
مع معاييرهما نحن ندرك جيدا انه بمجرد
توقف الاحتجاجات سيعدون الى اقصى ضغط لهما
مره اخرى
تلقت نقابتنا تقارير عن قيام رجال الشرطه
بملابس مدنيه باختطاف طلاب في الحرم
الجامعي والضرب عشوائي من قبل قوات متطوعه
وتسبب وابل الغاز المسير للدموع والقنابل
الصوتيه وطلقات الرصاص على الطلاب
المتظاهرين في حدوث الكسور في الجمجمه
واصابات في العين
ووثقت وكاله حقوق الانسان الايرانيه
احتجاجات في 144 جامعه على الاقل واكدت
اللجنه التطوعيه لمتابعه اوضاع المعتقلين
اعتقال نحو 700 طالب جامعي حكم على 44
منهم بالسجن لعده سنوات في كثير من
الاحيان وقالت لجنه اكثر من نصف المعتقلين
ما زالوا خلف القضبان ويواجه طالب واحد
على الاقل تهاما قد تستحق عقوبه الاعدام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]